I'm not eat milk is Right see ya Tiffany
I kept you try to tempt him yeah it's
late kept a heart Tiffany Haddish that
Bible hey what's going on I'm Kevin Hart
and I'm Tiffany at and call what this is
called what the snake what this snack
war snack war let's do it very well we
got okay all right and I'll take these
or you can take those what is this
that's about the run straight things up
yeah I know some okay I'm gonna try to
Tim Tam mmm you look like you just ate
that person that came over your house
and bought the potato salad you trying
to be nice it's like a grandma's let you
eat Oreo gum okay Tiffany Jesus great
what are you 13
put the damn thing about my stuff out
okay that just now wait a minute
Tiffany put it kids watching let's put
the damn cooking all right okay take a
bite too much other what do you like
better to tipped a more Oreos that's
what I just gave you two wonderful
better - yeah all right I'll go first
this is a lemon Tim look like quality it
smell good yeah I go joy I don't if I
pick if you pick the next day person up
why not take a real bite I'm going USA
again wake it tastes like you could wash
dishes witty
Twinkie was a safer bite no really
Sallah original limit okay think let me
taste dr. pepper
[Music]
Oh Tiffany yeah this is delicious
[Music]
that's not good
this is great yeah I'm going I go astray
I give us training one on that one what
[Music]
that veggie my stuff
I'm not even Tiffany I know what that is
this here ain't none of us some goddamn
Rocha banner hey I had it before oh god
oh god yes I told you
workers follow it tastes like bad breath
and medications yeah I don't know why
would they do that the kids here's your
lunch little walls he might hey what do
I have mom I got some Vegemite on some
white bread that's the peanut butter and
jelly when's that when I see big dick oh
I hate Budweiser south
[Music]
it tastes exactly the same no no no I
think I picked Australian was better
this is so harsh
no don't know that drink beer I know
what I'm doing now I like beer and I'm a
going straight yeah Australia's better
well Victoria better I'm gonna go to
Hills about what y'all need to put
burgers in a chip for you balls abate my
vitamins bladder and a burger mines way
better the Barbie doll Australia nothing
I'm a good boy really
crawl is alive frogs alive notice the
shape of a frog it's just the shape of a
frog isn't for frog labour no progress
little little sound
[Music]
if you try to prop my like it where I
can fill my face again I'll try
yeah what the situation is ah this is a
major bank it meant was this run is this
Verico this smell is not no yeah buzu
Jolly magnet time on mrs. O'Malley
American candy art you've been
hoodwinked you bit tricky this was a
Taiwanese first ISM Astra impressed was
in Taiwan versus oh so y'all can suck it
Australian wins
very good job alright well then you have
it Australian for the win
lad Bible as always fun don't know it
was a great experience whenever new
politeness and showing us thank you yeah
that Vegemite with mast they should lose
for creating yeah yeah that must have
been my jail food or something not
prison they love it